[Music]
hello welcome back to jk news today we
have another
am i the [ __ ] and i this one's very
fun okay
am i the [ __ ] for suddenly
disinviting my father four days before
my wedding
he even paid for my wedding and i
haven't spoken to him
i have to i have to know the reason yeah
right yeah i got another reason
four days before and he paid for it i
can't judge money
sometimes money they try to buy love
with money and that's [ __ ] up so i
gotta get the details another article
that we did
we did do a am i the [ __ ] that was
very similar the dad didn't want to go
but the dad didn't want to go to the
yeah yeah yeah
but but this one's the from the girl's
perspective yeah she doesn't want him to
go
what if it's the same family just to be
clear she got married early february
okay she's always been very close to her
father and stepmom growing up
she always felt like they offered her a
stable home for her to grow up in
she never had that with her mother
during the last few years of her parents
marriage her mother changed as a person
she was a happy and cheerful person when
we were younger
she really changed after the divorce she
was miserable and i felt that
she could tell that i hated the fact
that i preferred to live with my dad but
i never verbalized her feelings
very very smart she had been single
since the divorce and refuses to date
other people
this sounds exactly that sounds exactly
the other perspective yeah
dad's perspective yeah the exact same
story what just happens on reddit so i'm
scared yeah let's hear let's hear it
so far it sounds like the same story i
always wanted to have a joint birthday
parties with my mom dad and stepmom
so far so good it sounds different
already but my mom wouldn't have it she
avoided my father like the plague i
never understood her behavior i resented
her
for it quite naturally i preferred my
dad's household over my mom's
anyways right before my wedding i was
staying at my dad's one night over
heard my dad and my stepmom reminiscing
about how they met
now they always told us about how they
met six months after the divorce out of
the library it turns out they lied
they were talking about how my father
couldn't take his eyes off for the
moment she walked into his office
and how he wanted her from that moment
on also it was an affair
exactly and how he didn't care that he
had a pregnant wife at home
pregnant oh so sad imagine this was like
the last story
because the last story was talking about
how the the wife was in love with him
still
and she was oh the the ex-wife was in
love with them and she wanted to get
with them
it sounds like the same story because
it's two sisters right
no but then the the past wife cheated on
him listen
apparently this gets juicy okay okay
okay
soap opera oh my god but what if it was
two stories combined but it's
two different perspectives listen it
would be so good there's a lot of drama
out there
all right let's do it let's do it
apparently their first kiss was a few
days after i was born
oh oh she was the pre the the baby
maybe she was in the belly her mother
yeah
and the first time they had sex was on
my parents third anniversary
how did she hear so much in this
conversation yeah are they just
saying that [ __ ] he said all this [ __ ]
he's like remember when we had sex for
the first time
on monday it's a lot of exposition they
said they're actual dates
we do that sometimes we reminisce about
like and we go into details like we're
reliving it
remember that moment but i would never
be talking about like uh see
i i did that i cheated on this point i
would try to forget that time
yeah i remember when i cheated on with
you with my ex-wife
on my anniversary remember when my wife
was pregnant at home and i was
banging your guts like i felt so
bad because she was pregnant with leslie
and then i don't think that girl would
like that that you're even bringing that
up even though she knows what happens
but they're talking privately to each
other remember in 1988
we don't know we don't know how they are
we don't have there maybe they like to
reminisce also
maybe they just like to role play
because sometimes like i do that like
when we're kind of getting into the zone
i'm like
my boyfriend's going to be here and like
oh it's all worthwhile if they're
role-playing like sometimes like
listening to themselves your wife is
pregnant at home
no and i'm like take my little dick you
little stupid [ __ ]
they were talking about how difficult it
was for them to continue their
relationship after they got caught when
i was five
whoa they did a lot of exposition this
was extremely shocking to me because my
parents got divorced when i was 10.
they were also making fun of my mom's
weight
yeah what you almost broke a chair
this meant they carried out an affair
throughout my parents marriage
changing for the worst when i was in
second grade randomly
i always knew and she never told me i
broke down crying that night and felt
really guilty because the way i acted
towards my mom growing up yeah
i had no idea she went through so much i
cheated on my first boyfriend in college
and it destroyed me i felt horrible
guilt right so she grew up at this
house and or she enjoys this house more
yeah and she loves the stepmom
and she just didn't know she's like my
mom's a [ __ ] i
like she's always miserable i don't
understand why she's always depressed
all the time the stepmom
was a home wrecker and the [ __ ] daddy
was a cheater
exactly damn that sucks that's so sad so
she's like that night i could
i didn't confront my dad but the next
morning i packed my [ __ ] up and
transferred the amount he had spent on
my wedding i didn't want his money i
told him
i told him i heard everything and asked
him to stay away from my wedding
i left their house and drove to my mom's
i hugged her really hard and we both
quiet
i had my mom walk me down the aisle oh
beautiful i wanted to hold that i'm only
crying yeah
me too it's beautiful god damn
especially because the mom
had the strength to hold that secret
yeah not talk [ __ ] yeah
she didn't want her to hate her dad huh
stranded so she ended up
favoring the [ __ ] dead because she's
like if if you only knew you [ __ ]
little [ __ ]
i would not be able to keep my mouth
shut i'll be talking about so much [ __ ]
do you see this i wish i wish more
people pay attention to this because
this is where
women can be so strong not in sports
thank you hey whoa whoa take
your [ __ ] back where well against men
against men in sports
i think everyone's ever played
volleyball you've watched ufc lately
women are kicking ass women are really
good
at keeping quiet yeah when it counts oh
so true have you seen gymnastics
everything else
yeah yeah sure no secrets oh they get
hot in gymnastics
i had my mom walk me down the aisle and
i made sure my dad's family didn't
attend the wedding
i didn't explicitly disinvite my half
brother but he stayed away from my
wedding and i'm actually glad he did not
come i
don't think i want anything to do with
them anymore i've heard from the
grapevine that my dad is on
antidepressants nowadays my grandma
blames me for his
yeah it's not her fault did i overreact
[ __ ] [ __ ] did i overreact
i still don't want anything to do with
it my dad's family think i was and being
cool to him
because how they've treated her and
like she did favor them and those
memories she's not cherishing at all
so she's just seeing it as like hey it's
all alive
adult deceit she's she's personalizing
that
well she didn't get to process it was
four days before her wedding right so
she's at overreacting for
that moment and i think it was a little
bit like it's pretty [ __ ] up
he got caught though i mean he got
caught and then she's like
my wedding will be sullied by this [ __ ]
like my wedding will be it would because
it would be in the back of her mind now
you know why
i don't think she's overreacting is
because it's like
all it's almost like that whole
childhood was a lie because
you were oh the dad was okay with me
believing
that my mom is just a shitty person
that's miserable all the time for no
reason
out of the blue and doesn't accept any
responsibility like hey
i might have been the cause of your
mom's problem or whatever like
i don't know i feel like there should be
their affair turned like a such a
wonderful marriage
yeah but it all like killed our mom's
spirit yeah exactly completely
and and turned her mom into the enemy
that's what cheating can do to somebody
i know imagine you have a kid you love
that kid so much and now they don't like
you they don't spend time with you
you're already broken horrible man and
it's your mom
yeah and they'd rather be with the one
that [ __ ] cheated on you
oh yeah at that point i would have been
i'm bringing out the big guns
your daddy's a [ __ ] cheating son of a
[ __ ] it's not even cheating because
cheating i feel like is like a one-time
thing maybe you got wrapped up or
whatever
this is a [ __ ] decade-long affair
smorgasbord i like smarter sports
oh it's more [ __ ] up that there's kids
involved like like they started when the
wife was pregnant
that's what's [ __ ] up i heard that
happens a lot before
a whole family was started yes oh that's
crazy
and they keep referencing the affair
around when she was born
when and what age and how disrespectful
is that [ __ ]
you're like at the you got their
pre-wedding [ __ ] and you're like hey
remember when we were [ __ ]
and then that fun i mean they didn't
know anything yeah ain't that fun
it's like nuts maybe it was because i
would try to repress that [ __ ] and not
even bring it back up
right maybe because they're thinking
about when the girl would like oh my god
since she was this years old like it was
like before she was even born
like you've known her all her life right
and she didn't even know that you knew
her all over and then when she was five
and we got caught
and it's such a tainted way to get into
a relationship yeah
like for me when you get into things
like that
it's never pure thank you and something
happens
someone's gonna find out you might as
well just say it in the beginning
you will always have an underlying
mistrust for sure
for sure and this was the curse you're
[ __ ] sure man
the curse was your daughter found out
the truth
and now she turned on you yep mm-hmm oh
man
so who do you feel the worst for the dad
the mom the mom
i thought you would say that because he
got caught right
yeah yeah i wish he got away with his
car free i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding
no i feel bad for the daughter too
though yeah
because it's like she was dragged into
adult drama
i mean luckily she wasn't dragged into
when she was a kid yeah but kind of
ditched
she was now she was living alive
would've been more [ __ ] up if she took
the dad's money for the wedding and like
she should have kept the [ __ ] bad
money no i would have returned the money
like why
just to like have no ties whatsoever you
don't want that blood money on your hand
my head
like i paid for your wedding and you
didn't invite me no [ __ ] you here's your
money back i don't need you
like are you i deserve it i'm your child
would you have done that done what give
back the money yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah i think so i think i
would do it i want your blood money get
out of here you have too much pride
for me i'm looking at it this way i take
that motherfucker's money
now i got a discount now i gotta use my
money on buying a house
and guess what you [ __ ] owe me for
all the lines
is emotional truck i could charge your
ass more if you want to come back into
my house i can't explain it
i will extort the [ __ ] out of my dad me
even more
i got a dumb ass the other day because i
was like you know what why the [ __ ] did
you pay off your
debt yeah you could have died with debt
it would have been cleared you could
have had something left for me and my
brother what did you say
he was like no no it's better because if
i pay for the debt now
you guys don't have to pay that gets
inherited too did he say did he ever say
do you remember when he thought i was
dead lol
huh did he say do you remember when he
when you thought i was dead
for like a month yeah i know right i'm
like [ __ ] you still didn't die
oh damn yeah that's uh
that's [ __ ] up man that's rough but uh
yeah
out of principle i would not take it i'm
a very out of principle i don't think i
would either
like i do think sometimes just purely
out of principle i don't even want to do
it i just feel
bad but you don't think about the
discount that you would save on your
next mortgage
discount oh you could apply that to your
principal
you